meps approved the trade and cooperation
agreement with the uk
with 660 votes for and only five against
parliament will closely monitor the deal
ensuring that each side
sticks to its commitments
parliament adopted its position on a
kovit 19 certificate
that would allow safe and free movement
in the eu
it would include three categories proof
of vaccination
a negative covid19 test or a certificate
of recent recovery from the virus
parliament backed the landmark research
and innovation program
horizon europe with a budget of more
than 95 billion euros
it boosts funding for health systems
tackling climate change
and digitalization
a stronger civil protection framework
means the eu will be able to respond
faster to disasters in europe and
beyond funding for the mechanism will be
five times more than for the previous
seven years on average
digital businesses have a tax rate of
9.5 percent
much lower than the 23.2 percent average
for more traditional companies
meps want to update outdated
international tax rules to make them
[Music]
fairer